you're looking at history the USS
independence aircraft carrier human eyes
haven't seen this sunken ship which
fought ferocious battles in the Pacific
Theater in 65 years but now thanks to
the wonders of remotely operated
vehicles it's finally coming into view
the USS ends has had a rough go of it
the Navy nuked it twice and the infamous
bomb test in the Bikini Atoll eventually
the independence grew too leaky so the
Navy towed it off the coast and sank it
you might be wondering why on earth the
Navy wouldn't remove and reuse these
guns before nuking and sinking the
carrier well the whole point of nuking
the ship was to see how the blast would
affect things like weapons guns weren't
the only thing that Navy left behind
these are the remnants of a Hellcat
fighter plane and this is known as a
Christmas tree it was actually a sensor
for the nuclear blast see these holes
they used to have oil inside which would
rupture on impact
letting scientists measure the extreme
pressure of the explosions but not all
is death and destruction life is
flourishing here like giant sponges for
instance even though the radioactivity
has probably faded away expeditions like
these helped scientists figure out what
kind of life takes hold on shipwrecks
and by comparing the steel of the
independence and that of ships sunk of
Bikini Atoll researchers can determine
how water and radiation affect corrosion
that's based on observations at the
moment but later expeditions could
gather the carrier's medal for analysis
so rest well old independence and ungood